vincent
[Musique]
charlot bonjour majors n'ont forcément
pour lui sur internet qui s'appelle
thinker view nous sommes en direct est
ce que vous vous présenter succinctement
je
suis monique pinçon charlot je suis
sociologue je suis né en 1946 donc j'ai
73 ans et je suis marié avec michel
pinçon depuis fort longtemps et c'est
avec michel à qui je fais coucou que
j'ai écrit 25
livre à quatre mains donc avec lui sur
les dominants sur la caste sur
l'oligarchie avec
des enquêtes dans le cadre que j'ai
menée avec lui dans le cadre de notre
statut de chercheur au cnrs ce qui a été
évidemment une légitimité qui nous a
beaucoup ouvert les portes et voilà je
suis belge espère pour ça j'ai fait un
petit coucou à lui seul pour lui dire
que je vais essayer d'être à la hauteur
du cadeau que vous nous faites puisque
autant de temps pour que nous mais vous
avez vous allez voir que pour moi je le
vis comme un cadeau en tout cas je vais
voir si c'est pas un cadeau mais pour
l'instant je vis comme un cadeau et
voilà pouvoir développer sans être sans
être coupés sans être agressé comme
c'est souvent l'habitude dans les médias
traditionnels et même paradoxalement sur
les chaînes publiques bassam hallucine
toujours quand ça se passe pas bien pour
nous que la pensée critique peut pas
s'exprimer sur france 2 sur france 5 sur
maintenant souvent sur france inter
france culture c'est c'est quand même
terrible alors qu'il ya 10 ou 15 ans
avec michel on passait régulièrement
dans les médias vous avez senti une
tension un raidissement de des chaînes
publiques face à ce que vous avancez sur
l'étude de des riches ah oui ah ça c'est
très clair et par exemple je peux
prendre l'exemple de celle hebdo pour
notre dernier livre le président des
ultras riches sur emmanuel macron et
tous les cadeaux qu'il a fait aux plus
riches par dizaines de milliards d'euros
dès qu'il est arrivé à l'elysée eh bien
ah c'est l'hebdo g au total j'ai été
coupé je sais pas 58 fois enfin un
nombre incalculable apathie me gueuler
dessus comme un pitbull sur sa proie
parce que j'avais osé dire que la presse
n'était pas libre et qu'il n'était pas
d'accord et j'ai même été coupée donc si
vous voulez c'est quand même des choses
qui sont graves du coup le montage oui
j'ai été coupé au montage quand je lui
ai parlé du siècle pour savoir pourquoi
les journalistes allaient rencontrer les
hommes politiques au siècle tous les
mercredis les derniers mercredis de
chaque mois en se rendant aujourd'hui au
cercle de l'union interalliée 33 rue du
faubourg saint-honoré et donc voilà donc
là il s'est senti que le ton montait
alors acrimed
un organisme qui critiquent les médias
et qui fait un travail je trouve en tout
cas extraordinaire donc ça m'a fait
plaisir qu'ils aient fait ce travail sur
cette émission ils ont fait un
décryptage complet qui m'ont soumis que
j'ai validé j'essayais de me rappeler qu
est ce que j'avais pu dire qu'ils
puissent être censurée de qu'il soit
aussi grave est aussi dangereux et puis
au cours d'une insomnie je me suis bien
rappelé que c'était le siècle dont
j'avais parlé et donc j'ai attester que
c'était bien du siècle que j'avais parlé
que il n'avait pas supporté donc vous
avez étudié les résoudre pouvoir qu'est
ce que c'est le siècle qu'est ce que
c'est le siècle qu'est ce que c'est le
bgs2 le béa qu'est ce que c'est ce type
ce type de think tank de dîners de 2 oui
vous avez raison vous pourriez dire et
cetera et cetera parce que il y en a
énormément c'est ça la force de cette
oligarchie c'est de multiplier les
instances de coordination de
leurs rouerie et des rouages du
fonctionnement de cette classe et donc
il ya de multiples associations de
multiples cercles de multiples si mme
tang
à gauche aussi comme il ya rab et ça je
ne le dis pas le jeûne dis pas le
contraire mais en tout cas là je parle
de ce que ce sur quoi j'ai enquêté avec
michel et donc le siècle est un des uns
des cercles sur lequel nous n'avons pas
travaillé en 1986 quand nous avons
commencé michelle et moi à prévenir le
cnrs qu désormais nous travaillerions
tous les deux ensemble que nous
abandonnions pour michel avant d'oignons
provisoirement et puis pas pour nos
enquêtes la classe ouvrière les ouvriers
dans les ardennes michel et puis moi je
travaillais plus tôt sur les classes
moyennes instituteur fonctionnaires et
hauts fonctionnaires et
que nous allions travailler sur la très
grande bourgeoisie on commence la
journée par très grande bourgeoisie vol
alors ça je vais le préciser mais je
termine d'abord sur le siècle pendant
est donc ce qui est intéressant c'est
que justement pour essayer de comprendre
qu'est-ce que c'était cette grande
bourgeoisie on a eu cette idée géniale
de se dire on va essayer de se faire
introduire dans des rangs dans des
cercles alors donc on avait un premier
contact avec le jockey club rue rabelais
dans le 8e arrondissement qui est un
cercle de la de l'aristocratie de la
noblesse qui a été constituée au milieu
du 19e siècle sur la base de la passion
du cheval et
pour
avoir accès aux annuaires de ces cercles
qui évidemment ne sont pas publiques qui
sont pas enfermés dans des coffres forts
sous le sceau du secret absolu mais qui
peuvent être dans les bibliothèques de
ces cercles et donc on est arrivé
alors on rentrer par la grande porte aux
joutes les clubs mettant à 8h30 quand la
bibliothécaire madame marchand pouvait
nous recevoir on consultait les
annuaires on notait toutes les adresses
les noms les professions enfin vous êtes
tout un travail de sociologue et puis
après quand les membres arrivait qu'on
avait fini notre travail vers midi il
fallait qu'on sorte par la sortie de
l'entrée de service pour pas gêner les
membres et à cette époque là vous voyez
on n'a pas retenu le siècle pour faire
ce travail d'adressé de compilation
statistique parce que c'était un cercle
qui nous était apparu ne
pas appartenir à la grande bourgeoisie
est donc en 86 ça veut simplement dire
que à cette époque là la collusion entre
les médias et le monde politique n'était
pas aussi forte que celle que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
ça vous est passé simplement sous but
non je pense que c'était en fait en tout
cas je le vis toujours comme une analyse
sociologique assume et on a pu se
tromper mais en tout cas c'était assumé
de notre part tandis
qu'aujourd'hui oui on le retiendrait
parce que aujourd'hui la collusion des
élites mais en principe je me retire ce
terme d'élite parce que je n'emploie
jamais il est bien trop flatteur la
collusion de ces des membres de cette
caste cette classe dominante de cette
confrérie des grandes familles de cette
caste j'ai déjà dit 2
de ces prédateurs suivant comment je
suis en colère les mots peuvent changer
alors
c'est plus à l'est collusion
mais c'est sa voix l'a77 la collusion
les journalistes n'avaient pas le
pouvoir qu'ils ont aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment je reprend
la formule de serge halimi les nouveaux
chiens de garde de
2,7 grande bourgeoisie donc c'est quoi
la grande bourgeoisie vous n'avez pas
fait la franc maçonnerie au passage par
les confréries août chose comme ça non
parce que la franc maçonnerie est
beaucoup plus trans classiste là on
parle vraiment de la grande bourgeoisie
c'est à dire bourdieu
nous a beaucoup facilité la tâche avec
sa théorie de la sociologie de la
domination où il définissait cette
grande bourgeoisie à partir de quatre
formes de richesses très précise c'est
la richesse économique alors que la
richesse économique c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est quoi beaucoup c'est
ça le fait seul problème c'est que
précisément sur cette première richesse
vous
avez une dispersion absolument énorme
c'est à dire que dès que vous rentrez
dans le monde de la richesse vous vous
imaginez un iceberg vous voyez la face
visible puisque vous ne voyez pas c'est
ce qui est sous la mer et donc la grande
richesse je pourrais dire par exemple
que dans le dernier numéro de challenges
sur le palmarès des grandes fortunes il
y avait 400 fois la
fortune ne pas citer alain ducasse qui
était le 500e de ce palmarès il y avait
400 fois la 500e fortune dans la
première fortune de bernard arnault donc
une dispersion de 400 fois ça n'existe
pas dans le monde ordinaire des salaires
et des revenus donc une énorme
dispersion et donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant pour commencer à définir la
grande bourgeoisie de montrer que c'est
une classe sociale extrêmement
hétérogène
comment se fait-il alors qu'elles
forment une classe sociale au sens
marxiste du terme qu'elles soient
mobilisés au point où on va sûrement le
pouvoir le développer ici pour défendre
ses intérêts de classe c'est parce que
il y a trois autres formes de richesses
qui sont essentiels la
seconde c'est la richesse culturelle
donc on est dans le monde des grandes
fortunes le monde des collectionneurs
d'art le monde des propriétaires de
sociétés de vente aux enchères on est
dans des univers avec dédé des meubles
enfin toute forme et on est dans le
monde des grandes écoles des grands
lycées privés on est dans un monde
culturel qui est très éloigné c'est un
fossé qui sépare ce monde des classes
moyennes supérieures ensuite la
troisième forme de richesse c'est la
richesse sociale la richesse sociale ça
veut dire que le portefeuille des
relations sociales des membres de cette
classe est bien garni autrement dit
quand vous êtes invité à dîner il n'y'a
autour de la table que des gens
importants dans les différents secteurs
de l'activité économique et social
bon ça peut être un ministre ça peut
être un haut fonctionnaire un inspecteur
des finances un procureur de la
république ça
peut être un industriel un évêque puis
quelques fois il y avait deux
sociologues qui avec leur statut de
directeur de recherche au cnrs pouvait
pour leur travail être autour de cette
table avec
des des français des gens qui parlaient
français et puis des étrangers est notre
premier dîner avec michel je me souviens
très bien c'était dans un hôtel
particulier du 16e arrondissement
on s'est senti trop trop mal trop mis de
côté parce qu'il parlait sans arrêt de
manière naturelle français anglais et
espagnol qu'après on est passé à des à
des langues un peu plus compliqué mais
ces volailles donc là on a compris que
cette grande bourgeoisie était certes
hétérogène mais voilà déjà trois formes
de richesses économiques culturelles et
sociales et alors la dernière qui est le
top c'est ce que bourdieu appelait la
richesse symbolique le capital
symbolique c'est une forme de richesse
qui vient symboliser les trois autres
formes de richesses et qui se manifeste
de la manière suivante excusez
moi je prends un petit peu d'autres pas
comme à la maison vous m'avez dit alors
et qui vient symboliser donc les autres
formes de richesses donc mettons on est
invités avec michel un cocktail yahia
guy de rothschild qui étaient là bas il
est mort et dont il était là et lui il
est présenté et on se présente parce que
tout le monde faire crises fema
fournirait des guides rothschild et nous
on nous présentait mois puisque c'est
moi qui suis là aujourd'hui à l'honneur
monique pinçon-charlot directrice
du recherche du centre national de la
recherche scientifique disait pas les
six ans national de la recherche
scientifique c'est à dire autrement dit
moi je n'avais pas d'autres formes de
richesses que mon statut professionnel
comme mon capital professionnel tandis
que guy de rothschild en disant que son
patronyme familial ce patronyme familial
symbolise à lui seul l'ensemble des
richesses de cette famille liée à la
banque et à la haute finance depuis là
depuis le début du 19e siècle et autres
formes de richesse symbolique les
corps il
faut que les corps de
ces gens-là manifestent leur supériorité
ce sont toujours des décors phare dressé
par exemple n'y a jamais de franges sur
le front le port de tête doit le port de
tête est dégagée altier
même quand on se retrouve comme on s'est
retrouvé michel et moi à chantilly temps
au pique nique du grand prix de diane
c'est toujours à la au mois de juin il
va y avoir le grand prix de diane très
bientôt y
pique nique ils sont à quatre pattes par
terre mais c'est incroyable nous si on
est à quatre pattes en train de
pique-niquer on se rajouter sais pas
comment vous dire et tandis que même les
enfants ils sont toujours droit même à
quatre pattes par terre en train de
manger parce que c'est un facteur de
reconnaissance sociale voilà c'est un
facteur et c'est plus que ça je vais
vous dire c'est plus fort que ça c'est à
dire que ils
sont avec le cette incorporation de
leurs privilèges il transforme
l'arbitraire de ses privilèges en
qualité naturelle c'est à dire qu' il
n'y sont pour rien que vous soyez né à
neuilly ou à bobigny franchement vous y
êtes pour rien vous êtes né à neuilly
votre vie va être faite de pétales de
roses et à bobigny d'épinés épouvantable
à neuilly vous allez hérité dans la
bouche de votre naissance des titres de
propriété qui ont été accumulées par les
générations précédentes tandis qu à
bobigny vous allez a hérité d'un père au
chômage enfin des dettes de tous les
toutes les difficultés qui marque les
lacs et les pauvres l'aigle et les
classes les plus démunis qu'est ce que
je pourrais donner comme autre
manifestation de cette richesse
symbolique parce que je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est si important ça peut être
le château classé monument historique
avoir
chatte habilité à château classé
monument historique recevoir toute la
famille les grands toujours des grandes
familles alors ça c'est bien et on a
fait une livre à ces impertinents
michelle et moi sur les châteaux et les
châtelains et ont posé la question
qu'est-ce qui est classée est ce que
c'est le château où est ce que c'est le
châtelain et bien souvent on était
capable de montrer que c'était le
châtelain grâce à ses réseaux de
connaissances grâce à un plein de choses
qui qui pouvait aider à classer monument
historique le château de quelqu'un qui
avait beaucoup de relations et pas celui
de quelqu'un qui avait pas de pas
beaucoup de relations et donc c'est pour
ça que il n'y a pas beaucoup de canards
boiteux de brebis galeuses qui quitte la
grande bourgeoisie parce que les jeunes
qui pourrait contester pourrait
contester leur tout simplement le mode
de vie de cette classe ne pas avoir
envie de s'y épanouir et d'y vivre
il porte un patronyme familial ce
patronyme familial c'est une richesse et
donc cette richesse là il faut pas la
salir et du coup le le groupe se
mobilise pour remettre la brebis
galeuses dans le troupeau je
n'ai jamais entendu ce jeudi les d'âge
qui est je viens à vous sans mes titres
mais uniquement avec mes succès alors
là les titres c'est eux qui les ont et
le problème c'est qu'ils ont les succès
c'est à dire que c'est une classe où on
est toujours toujours dans le cumul nous
dans les classes moyennes au cnrs et
puis même dans la vie politique de
la gauche on est toujours dans des
divisions des oppositions des faux
débats dans la grande bourgeoisie ils
sont toujours dans le cumul le cumul des
richesses le cumul des énergies de
chacun par exemple on a fait un travail
spécifique un livre spécifique
uniquement sur la famille rothschild et
là on voit bien comment quand on prend
une famille avec tous les membres des
différentes branches de cette famille
comment si le fils aîné de telle branche
est pas trop intéressé par reprendre la
succession dans la banque et la finance
parce que il est passionné de chasse à
courre il est passionné de peinture il
est passionné de d'autres choses de
théâtre par exemple je pense à henry
qu'à
cela ne tienne c'est pas un problème
l'essentiel c'est d'être excellent dans
son choix
parce que de toute façon les grands des
grandes familles ça c'est une expression
de pierre bourdieu et on trouvera
toujours un neveu pour prendre la
succession dans
la banque la finance dans
les affaires qui sont le coeur nucléaire
du de la richesse de la famille quelle
est l île et les conversations de ses
salons feutrés quels
étaient les sujets les plus abordés
qu'ils étaient le vocabulaire la
sémantique employés alors
c'était c'était
c'est vrai que c'était un vocabulaire
quand même avec des expressions
spécifiques par exemple je me souviens
le donc le comte cayenne d'anvers quand
c'est moi qui ai fait la première le
premier entretien dans la noblesse avec
ce monsieur qui
m'a reçu dans son hôtel particulier dans
le xvième on a fait un entretien de
trois heures il avait 78 ans et c'était
passionnant il m'a raconté des choses
extraordinaires parce que sa famille il
est très lié à la famille rothschild
lazare et tout ça et avec une vie à
l'échelle de la planète complètement
cosmopolite des affaires au paraguay en
argentine enfin des trucs incroyables
lui qui pilotait son avion il avait à
peine 17 ans enfin bref une vie
d'aventurier de demain
voilà une vie extraordinaire donc
j'enregistre et puis j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il était intéressé par faire ses
mémoires lors à la fin je lui dit très
gentiment d' si vous voulez moi j'étais
très intéressé par cet entretien je
pourrais vous recopiez les cassettes et
puis ça pourra peut-être vous aider pour
les mémoires et puis quand je suis
rentré à la maison michel m'a dit ah ben
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé avec cet
homme donc ce soir et nous invite à un
dîner il a dit que ça serait amusant
qu'on soit là donc le qualificatif
amusant revient très souvent les femmes
disaient que michel était exquis bon
c'est pas des mots que j'avais
l'habitude de voir employés et puis
sinon j'ai été frappée au à d'autres
moments par des des mots très crus ce
que j'ose pas dire la médée non merci
votre gentillesse mais je ne sais pas je
me rappelle plus mais très crue voilà
des sinon
un contrôle total du langage un contrôle
total des conversations il faut toujours
avoir quelque chose à raconter il n'y a
pas de silence y les anecdotes sont
toujours les bienvenues mais il faut
qu'elle soit drôle il faut alors au bout
d'un certain temps on s'est rendu compte
qu'il répétait toujours les mêmes
anecdotes il
faut avoir de la conversation il faut
que tout le monde parle voilà c'est ce
que je peux dire dans un printemps dans
un premier jet quel était le la façon de
servir les plats la façon de manger
c'était une conversation de kourou
c'était une conversation plus
charpenté c'était
en gros est ce que c'était un dîner de
cons vous avez été conviés alors
merci que j'ai comment ça ça serait un
petit peu mais je pense que d'une
certaine façon on pourra y revenir dans
la suite de la discussion c'est ça qui
est qui est un peu gênant dans notre
histoire c'est que tout se passe comme
si on les légitimes est d'une certaine
façon parce que au départ quand on s'est
intéressé à eux on avait notre statut de
chercheur au cnrs on était moi j'avais
40 ans 86 michel 44 on était un peu
timide michalet d'origine ouvrière je
suis origine origine petite bourgeoise
de lozère donc vraiment très loin quand
même l'un et l'autre de façon différente
très très loin de la grande bourgeoisie
parisienne de
telle sorte que alors
je sais plus je voulais où j'entre où
j'allais façon de dérouler le cultiver
oui les manières alors donc aude donc au
départ alors donc on les légitimait et
du coup nos questions et est plus centré
sur les modes de vie sur la culture sur
la transmission des héritages sur la
chasse à courre par exemple on a fait
trois ans sur des vélos tout terrain
dans toutes les forêts de france à
courir derrière le cers mais en réalité
c'était pour pouvoir participer au dîner
au pique nique dans la forêt avec les
grands équipage de chasse à courre et on
a drôlement bien fait de faire ce
travail parce que ça nous a ouvert
beaucoup de beaucoup de portes on
essayait de toujours essayer de pénétrer
de pénétrer avec nos moyens à nous je
sais qu'il ya bien d'autres moyens
beaucoup plus peut-être efficace nous
c'était des moyens d'être no love
d'anthropologues voyait deux sociologues
d'économistes de chercheurs en sciences
sociales j'avais vu les méthodes de
brigands les les méthodes de grieg oh
non enfin on était brigands on sentait
brillant à notre façon mais brigands
parce que être brigand c'est c'est
toujours un peu relatif par rapport en
comparaison avec les autres nous ont
trouvé que déjà faire ce travail michel
et moi c'était vraiment un pertinent par
rapport à ce qui se passait à ce
moment-là au cnrs le chili bus tuerie
voilà mais on se vide est plutôt comme
des comme des acrobates tombera tombera
pas et
donc quand notre premier livre paraît
aux éditions du seuil dans les beaux
quartiers
on
avait fait notre travail comme pour pour
les autres classes sociales
automatiquement en mettant pseudonyme à
tout le monde et étrangers sur les
banlieues question internet en question
nos têtes avez vous travaillé sur les
banlieues sur les banlieues à neuilly
oui alors alors
oui oui on a travaillé alors moi j'ai
fait un gros travail statistique sur
l'ensemble de la région parisienne pour
connaître l'offre d'équipements publics
à un gros travail statistique que j'ai
fait avec l'insee l'offre d'équipements
publics en fonction justement des
différentes catégories
socioprofessionnelles et donc je peux
vous assurer que la banlieue est était
vraiment largement dépourvu que ce soit
en force de police que ce soit en
qualité des écoles des hôpitaux des
moyens de transport par rapport à la
banlieue ouest
et c'est d'ailleurs au vu de ces
résultats que avec michel on s'est dit
bah ça serait quand même vraiment
intéressant de deux
de
faire des investigations sociologique
précisément sur les dominants alors là
vous me déstabiliser puisque du coup
c'est plus où j'en suis revenons à notre
beau linge oui votre travail de de
flibustiers d'acrobates oui a essayé de
pénétrer les cercles qui était censé
être en dehors de votre portée sociale
oui savez
ça vous est venu comme ça ce que vous
aviez simplement l'envi scientifique de
pénétrer de faire remonter pour
l'intérêt général comment ça se passe et
où c'était plus une vision plus
politique je dirais de hackers
communiste qui va pénétrer ce type de
cercle non alors j'ai fait tout est vrai
dans votre question tout est bon mais du
coup ça se tasse oppose pas on peut être
tout ça en même temps dans la mesure ce
qui nous notre
projet à michel et moi ça
avait été 2e on était proches quand on
était jeunes du parti communiste et que
j'ai d'ailleurs auprès de la france sont
soumises dont vous avez été opérée
j'ai eu quelques jours l'investiture de
la france insoumis voilà des plus tôt tu
vois là elle qui m'a été retirée très
vite donc mais enfin peu importe et on
voit là et donc on était impressionné
par le fait que au plus haut niveau même
du parti communiste les dirigeants
parlait toujours du grand capital à
notre époque il parlait du capitalisme
monopoliste d'état et nous avec michel
on s'est dit si un jour en comment on
était déjà un peu dans la recherche si
un jour on a les moyens d'être maîtres
de nos sujets qu'on puisse avoir de
l'autonomie nous c'est ça qu'on fera on
mettra du du sang et de la chair sur le
squelette de la domination c'est à dire
qu'on va personnifier
les capitalistes on va personnifier tous
les rouages qui sont nécessaires pour la
mobilisation de cette classe dans la
défense de ses intérêts ils
défendent leurs intérêts communs on
a promis en appauvrissant les banlieues
est on met en moins de police en
employer les appauvrissent comment
est-ce que c'est une démarche
intellectuelle volontaire c'est
à dire que c'est une classe sociale au
sens alors je sais que ça va vous
paraître peut-être regard mais c'est
comme ça c'est là en tout cas nous ça
nous paraît parfaitement en phase avec
l'actualité
c'est une classe sociale au sens
marxiste du terme c'est à dire que c'est
une classe en soit je les marque et je
les dis avec les différentes formes de
richesses qui sont qui
sont la marque de fabrique de cette
classe est
qui et qui est un milieu de deux mois de
la masse des gens la masse des français
de la masse des peuples c'est à dire que
c'est un vrai c'est pas des inégalités
sous
forme d'une échelle non c'est des
inégalités des inégalités c'est une
échelle jusqu'aux classes moyennes
supérieures puis après c'est un grand
fossé qui nous sépare de la classe sur
laquelle nous avons mené nos recherches
et
l'affût désolé je glisse ça va être
horrible alors si je vais vous aider un
peu près
il
matérialise les usa s'étaient alors donc
non mais faut la leur faut bien que vous
me suivez pas ce que je disais en soi et
après comme vous êtes très cultivé vous
saviez que là la seconde chose c'est
pour soi pour qu'il ya une classe au
sens marxiste du terme en soi et pour
soi c'est à dire consciente de ses
intérêts de classe conscience
d'appartenir à une classe et donc
comment
se manifeste et je vous remercie de
cette question parce qu'elle est
vraiment fondamental comment se
manifeste cette conscience de classe
est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de sociologues
et de statisticiens pour dire qui en est
et qui n'en est pas eh bien non c'est
eux-mêmes par le système de la
cooptation qui décide qui appartient à
cette classe et qui n'y appartiens pas
alors par exemple je peux vous donner un
exemple quand valéry giscard d'estaing a
été élu président de la république en
1974 si ma mémoire est bonne non je dois
me tromper oui c'est ça 74 giscard
d'estaing
il s'est dit bon maintenant je suis
président de la république je dois
pouvoir poser
ma candidature aux ok club le cercle de
l'aristocratie dont j'ai déjà parlé tout
à l'heure et il a posé sa candidature il
a trouvé deux parrains qui se sont
mobilisés pour que sa candidature soit
accepté et puis quand on vote enfin
c'est pas moi mais quand ils votent dans
des petites dans des petites mesures
avec des boules noires et des boules
blanches sont franc maçonnerie voilà
voilà il faut qu'ils aient pas je me
souviens plus du ratio en tout cas il a
eu il n'a pas pu il n'a pas été cooptés
parce que sa particule n'était pas une
vraie particules parce que voilà pour
des raisons qui leur appartiennent je
dis ça pour essayer de bien faire
comprendre que c'est une classe qui est
mobilisée par exemple pour les enfants
ce sont les mères de famille qui
cooptent les enfants qui vont faire
partie du rallye qu'elle dirige pour
leurs enfants parce qu'il ya non
seulement les cercles pour les adultes
mais dès le plus jeune âge il y a les
rallyes pour les enfants afin que les
enfants apprennent à aimer leurs
semblables en amitié puis en amour pour
être sûr que ligne
aura pas de mes alliances parce que ça
c'est le truc de fou une mésalliance
c'est terrible puisque il ne faut
surtout pas que l'argent ruisselle vers
les autres classes sociales
donc il faut que de génération en
génération les
pouvoirs et les richesses soient bien
reste bien dans la même confrérie de ces
grandes familles mais
jamais un système araji vous connaissez
des gens qu'on assistera ali oui oui on
nage après ce que c'est toujours autant
les beuveries les parties de jambes en
l'air complètement débridée la prise de
drogue qu'est ce que c'est toujours
comme ça alors ça je ne sais pas moi je
vois ce qui se passe quand ce que j'ai
vu tout ce que vous en raconter qu'on
voit à la télévision qu'on voit dans des
livres et tout ça nous on n'a jamais été
invité à une soirée de rallye on n'a
jamais été invité à un mariage tudor lit
un week end au rallye on n'a jamais été
invités à une grande fête de famille
c'est à dire que on voyait bien les
limites des invitations pouvait être
invité à passer un week-end au château
mais c'est pas pareil que être invité à
une fête de famille ou à un mariage vous
voyez avec vous soyez témoin du cousin
qui n'était pas content c'est ça on ne
sait pas on ne sait pas je pense que
c'était une intimité
voilà quelque chose que l on appelle le
plus dehors je ne je ne pense pas que ce
soit ça je l'aï marqué les limites je
pense que c'était des limites des
limites de corps par exemple quand j'ai
demandé une fois est ce que on était
invité dans des cercles il y avait des
piles ya des piscines et quand je me dis
un jour mais est ce que ça serait
possible que je puisse nager annoncé
enfin j'ai compris que j'avais commis
que ma question était le mélange pas les
corps quoi mélange pas les corps oui
c'est moi qui disent ah ça c'est moi qui
le dit bon
revenons à nos moutons je voulais comme
à la maison est
ce que vous foutez oui oui
mais alors alors
là c'est c'est toute une évolution dans
ma vie parce que je suis né en 46 donc
les femmes ont eu le droit de vote en 45
et donc comme je suis une petite femme
je
dirais pas féministe mais on enfin un
rebelle je me suis dit je me faisais
toujours eu envie de voter j'avais
vraiment envie de pouvoir m'exprimer et
bien entendu aujourd'hui le vote est
tellement dévoyé
manipuler construit
par cette oligarchie pour que
les eaux plus que vous parlez vous
avions qui volent et les gens votent
ondes âme et conscience tout mais pas du
tout alors c'est manipuler les véhicules
zemmamouche c'est bien mais c'est
manipuler très en amont par les
instituts de sondage pourquoi est ce que
les milliardaires investissent
dans les instituts de sondage pourquoi
est ce que les milliardaires
investissent dans les médias si c'est
pas pour nous traficoter les cerveaux
pour obtenir contre
notre propre gré notre consentement
aller
dans telle ou telle direction est
donc là alors pour ces européennes
macron qui fit qui dit qu'il va faire de
la proportionnelle qui fixe le seuil le
plus élevé d'europe 5%
voilà c'était décourageant de si les
gens se font manipuler par des
milliardaires oui et des instituts de
sondage 1 et c'est peut-être qu'il le
mérite non s'ils
n'ont pas un esprit critique si l'on pas
une autodéfense intellectuelle s'ils se
laissent s'il se complaisent dans cette
douce torpeur et moi de torpeur aussi
permet alors les doutes yeux c'est à
dire que le mérite je ne sais pas ma
façon de parler c'est à dire que quand
vous êtes le nez sur le guidon que vous
avez la vie tellement dur que vous avez
les gosses à aller chercher être donné
le bain il n'y a pas d'argent pour pour
manger que c'est la galère commence
comme les gilets jaunes ont raconté leur
vie
de galère en galère c'est
pas vrai on a pas on n'a pas la
possibilité de d'avoir
l'esprit critique et on a d'autant moins
la possibilité d'avoir l'esprit critique
que la pensée critique est absente
totalement des grands médias on est dans
un honnête mans moi je parle comme je
parle on
est dans une dictature qui ne dit pas
son nom c'est à dire que c'est le monde
d'orwell 1984 avec un parti unique alors
nous c'est pas un parti unique mais
c'est la pensée unique parce que que
vous passiez sur france 2 j'ai parlé de
35 mais que ce soit tf1 la même semaine
je suis passé à ces news de bolloré est
assez l'hebdo c'est là c'est la même
chose
la pensée critique n'a plus sa place on
ne peut rien dire on est muselée et
donc
obligé de préciser quand on l'appelait
balle à la tête dans le guidon il faut
aussi rajouter car les situations
stressantes active dans le cerveau des
comportements primitifs qui sont des
réflexes de protection et ça a tendance
à fait un rendre les gens stressés ça
les empêche de réfléchir correctement
je vous laisse continuer oui on se sait
qu'il est les neurosciences sont très
utilisés
les la psychanalyse les sciences
humaines et les sciences sociales sont
très utilisés dans toutes ces
manipulations idéologiques
linguistique
et corporelle et
donc et donc c'est pour ça que je suis
contente d'être là avec vous aujourd'hui
parce que la transmission
du savoir la transmission tout simple je
vous reparle de nos enquêtes bien trop
savoir et de veau au pied d'oeuvre oui
et c'est pas ça que j'ai dit est
donc ce
que je raconte je pense que c'est bien
pour les veaux auditeurs que c'est bien
d'entendre d'entendre
une parole simple mais
que je souhaite efficace et que je
souhaite pouvoir aider
en tout cas quand nous avec michel le
qu'est ce que je vous dirais le 17
novembre c'était l'acteur inde et gilet
jaune donc là on était à manosque et on
était avec une en faisait une rencontre
et du coup on sort on n'a pas pu aller
les rejoindre mais on a été stupéfait de
voir le nombre de gilet jaune qui était
surtout les pare brise et tout ça donc
après le samedi suivant on y est allés
sur les champs-elysées l'ont été à paris
et franchement on a été surpris venaient
vers nous on avait des discussions
formidable
c était extraordinaire donc si vous
voulez pour
nous c'est formidable d'avoir des
occasions de transmettre à des gens qui
n'ont pas le temps qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps d'avoir accès aux savoirs qui
n'ont pas accès aux savoirs de pouvoir
transmettre de cette façon là
aujourd'hui par des bd des films on a
fait avec michel par exemple l'été on va
dans des campings du ccas ddf enfin on a
fait ça quand on était plus jeunes plus
maintenant avec des jeux apéro tour des
grandes fortunes toutes les toutes les
formes de contact comme ça pédagogique
proches humains pour
transmettre la violence de classe la
violence des riches
ce matériel comment alors ces violences
et le regard dédaigneux c'est quoi non
c'est c'est
une force collective une classe sociale
comme je les dis mobilisés et cette
mobilisation
donc j'ai montré comment elle passait
par la cooptation et elle passe aussi et
c'est ça qui est important et ça ne
s'oppose pas si tout marche ensemble par
la sociabilité mondaine c'est à dire que
ils sont toujours entre eux toujours en
train de faire la fête avec du champagne
si bien que nous sommes avec michel on
s'était dit il va falloir qu en convoi
avec la médecine du travail au cnrs que
si on attrape une cirrhose ça soit
reconnu comme maladie professionnelle
quelque chose comme ça et
parce qu'il y avait volé en buvaient
beaucoup de champagne c'était toujours
très festif et en participant avec
michel à toutes ces fêtes à tous ces
cocktails à toutes ces soirées premières
d'opéra vernissage et tout ça pas
du tout et il ne s'emmerde pas et c'est
pas du tout des mondanités ringarde et
tout ça c'est leur travail leur travail
ils sont toujours en train d'échanger
sur les affaires enfin dans la fête mais
n'empêche que c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et et et on s'était rendu compte
que ce n'est pas acquis
rend service à b et puis b qui lui
renvoie l'ascenseur non c'est chaque
membre de cette classe qui est en
permanence rend service à tous membres
de cette classe en tout lieu et en tout
instant le bouquet est absolument une
classe sociale mobilisés dans la défense
ses intérêts que ce soit que vous soyez
que vous fassiez de la politique que
vous fassiez que vous soyez dans
l'écrivain que vous soyez grand avocat
que vous soyez
propriétés sont tous propriétaires
puisqu'ils ont tous maintenant des
actions que
vous soyez un grand dans le 16e
arrondissement on a rencontré beaucoup
d'agriculteurs mais
c'étaient des propriétaires de d'actares
et d'hectares de blé voilà nom de bosses
de blé de de betteraves ce n'était pas
des métayers on
va passer à cliquer sur l'internet pour
revenir à nos questions est ce que vous
avez lu le livre de juan branco qu'est
ce que vous pensez de son travail alors
donc j'ai lu le livre de juan branco
crépuscule
c'est celui là et bah écoutez moi il ya
des choses qui m'ont beaucoup intéressé
parce que nous on a beaucoup écrit par
exemple sur les grandes écoles de la
bourgeoisie les pleins de glisser
d'école mais je veux toujours ces voix
là mais c'est vrai qu'on n'avait jamais
écrit sur l'école alsacienne donc ça
nous a intéressés tout ce qu'il raconte
sur l'école alsacienne sur la
personnalité le personnage de gabrielle
attal qui est aujourd'hui très en vue
auprès d' emmanuel macron voit là bas il
est je trouve qu'il est il est jeune il
est fougueux et il présente comme
extraordinairement
originale des choses que nous nous
savions se dire on n'a pas appris grand
chose sur le fonctionnement de
l'oligarchie avec cet ouvrage certains
certains le décrivent comme
conspirationnistes oui je vous pose une
question internet est il possible de
parler de ces collusions sans être
amalgamés ou conspirationnisme alors
que c'est un réflexe de cette caste pour
discréditer décrédibiliser vos arguments
oui c'est ça alors c'est clair que c'est
une nous décrédibilise où les
journalistes qui veulent nous
stigmatiser d'emblée nous traite de
complotiste et nous on
c'est vrai que c'est objectivement c'est
bien qu'une classe qui qui complotent à
bilderberg la trilatérale ils sont
toujours entre eux ils discutent ils
échangent et tout ça 6 mai 2010 mur non
non non j'ai bon jeu plus dur qui vont
plus tôt mais justement je dis qu'ils
échangent mais qu'on pourrait dire
qu'ils complotent et
nous avec michel non on dit que en tout
cas nous on ressent pas ça dans notre
travail on dit qu'on a on s'est efforcé
de montrer le fonctionnement d'une
classe sociale qui défend qui défend ses
intérêts et qui en défendant ses
intérêts détruit détruit les détruit
les peuples enfin nous on parle même
d'une guerre que les plus riches mène
contre les peuples aujourd'hui mais par
rapport aux complotisme oui c'est une
façon c'est un raccourci pour pour
pas montré ce qui est important c'est à
dire que ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de montrer que tout est fait pour
masquer l'arbitraire de ce qui fait les
privilèges de ces gens là et c'est quoi
cet arbitraire c'est le fait comme je
les dis qu'ils sont nés à neuilly et
qu'ils ont hérité massivement il ya des
nouveaux riches mais massivement hérité
des titres de propriété puis qu'après
ils font fructifier pour passer ensuite
à la génération suivante mais si vous
voulez mais c'est un arbitraire total et
du coup on est là face à des géants aux
pieds d'argile parce que du jour au
lendemain c'est pas difficile de dire
les titres de propriété ne peuvent plus
permettre d'exploiter la force de
travail des autres la propriété c'est le
vol et on abat le système capitaliste
sur lequel est fondé cette
classe sociale propriétaire
des titres de propriété des moyens de
production des médias et voilà est ce
que vous pensez vous par les médias est
ce que vous pensez que certains
journalistes sont les porte flingues de
cette idéologie l'un à tout a fait d
nous abat je dirais de bfm enfin toutes
les toutes les chaînes qui appartiennent
aux 1 lagardère bolloré arnault pinault
blood
ou bailleurs
de presse ils ont peut-être une carte de
presse non parce que ils se hissent ont
dansé ils sont dans ces médias ils
mangent au râtelier de ses milliardaires
et honnêtement même à leur insu c'est
les nouveaux chiens de garde ça y'a pas
de problème parce que je suis
suffisamment passé dans ces médias pour
savoir comment c'est difficile d'imposer
une
autre façon de parler une autre parole
un autre contenu révolution
internet autre question d'internet les
oligarques sont-ils solidaires entre eux
alors
la solidarité de la solidarité de classe
et est essentielle puisque
c'est par cette solidarité là que vous
gardez votre votre statut parce que
votre statut il ne tient finalement bien
sûr aux titres de propriété que vous
avez mais c'est
c'est comme dans la noblesse il ya tout
ce capital symbolique toute cette
reconnaissance qu'il faut avoir et qui
est très importante il faut que tous
quand je disais que la sociabilité
mondaine c'était un travail de tous les
instants et de tous les jours c'est
parce que c'est norbert elias qui a
écrit dans la société de cours des pages
superbes sur le fait qu'il fallait
toujours prouver que l'on en était il
faut sans cesse être là présent là où il
faut
être dans les clous être d'en savoir
même dépenser de l'argent jeter de
l'argent par les fenêtres parce qu'en
réalité c'est de l'argent symbolique
c'est une richesse symbolique de la
reconnaissance qui va vous retombez en
retour vous avez étudié un peu l'auto
mais l'automobile club oui qu'est-ce que
c'est l'automobile eh ben c'est un grand
cerf qui a été créés au 19e siècle à
faire à la fin du 19e siècle quand
l'automobile les premières automobiles
sont apparus et les premières
automobiles étaient des des biens de
luxe qui était réservé de fait aux
grands bourgeois fortunés et c'était
extraordinaire parce que donc
l'automobile club est en bas des champs
elysées et les grands carrossiers de
l'époque de dion bouton et tout ça était
sur les champs elysées c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya toujours
encore renaud peut-être peugeot donne
des noms de sociétés qui ne sont
peut-être plus mais enfin l'automobile
est toujours sur marque bien les champs
elysées parce que l'automobile était
vraiment un bien de luxe et donc ils se
sont regroupés au sein de ce cercle qui
est pas du tout à un cercle qui a un
cercle très très chic très huppé très on
n'y a été plusieurs fois aux mêmes avec
michel on a participé à des
parties pas tout à fait de bordeaux nous
on n'avait pas fait tout le rallye avec
des vieilles voitures je me souviens à
michel il était dans une voiture avec
robert panhard comme conducteur et puis
après moi ça s'était pas passé comme ça
on après il a dû changer de c'était un
autre conducteur il a descendu tous les
champs elysées le c'était une vieille
voiture vous voyez c'était un et il n'y
avait pas de frein et donc et la police
a laissé passer cet homme il a grillé
tous les feux mais parce que c'était
c'était des gens de la haute qui allait
directement à l'automobile club il n'y a
pas eu d'amendé n'y a pas eu de coup de
sifflet ni rien du tout et donc
l'automobile club ben qu'est ce que je
peux vous dire j'ai été plusieurs fois
alors une fois toujours avec michel
puisqu'on est toujours en couple alors
ça j'ai pas j'ai pas dit ça tout à
l'heure à propos de la famille et vous
m'avez pas posé la question comment vous
avez fait pour rentrer je pense que le
fait qu'on soit un couple c'est à dire
déjà à nous deux une petite famille et a
été très important ce que la famille est
au coeur du dispositif de la
mobilisation de cette classe puisque il
faut transmettre la grande richesse doit
se projeter dans l'avenir des
générations futures
et
donc on a toujours été ensemble à
l'automobile club et une fois c'était le
bottin mondain qui organisait une fête
en 2003 pour fêter le centenaire du
bottin mondain et blanche de kersaint la
directrice du bota mandat nous avait
demandé si on serait d'accord pour faire
un article à l'intérieur de la petite
brochure qui serait remis aux invités il
y avait des des commerciaux qui est de
ce qui faisait de la publicité dans le
bottin mondain voilà c'était donc à
l'automobile club et nous on était là
auront de thébaux comme tout on était
pris en photo et puis on était on
avait notre place qu'on avait écrit dans
la brochure on était présente et enfin
c'était une place importante
et une autre fois on le directeur de
l'automobile club nous faisait visiter
les locaux de l'automobile club parce
que jean christophe rosé qui faisait un
film sur nous deux souhaitaient faire
quelque chose dans l'automobile club
donc on était en visite et on avait mis
nos sacs à dos dans un dans un salon à
l'invitation du directeur et puis quand
on va récupérer nos sacs à dos michelle
et moi on ouvrait que y avait plein
d'hommes avec les cheveux un peu coiffé
comme dominique de villepin tous avec le
même genre de costume et enfin d'une
élégance
une atmosphère de pouvoir incroyable qui
se dégage et comment ils nous ont
regardés avec
un air vraiment presque méchant enfin on
a été vraiment pas notre place à la vite
on a pris nos sacs à dos et on est parti
mais jamais on oubliera ce sentiment là
qu'on a ressenti du pouvoir d'un pouvoir
du
rpt d'un pouvoir violent d'un pouvoir
pas
tendres nous dire nous nous infiltrer
des desserts comme ça on va trouver les
gens seuls
triste alcoolique ayant
des pathologies toujours à raconter même
chose vous n'avez pas du salon gco
je comprends qu'on puisse voir ça
simplement c'est ce qui à ce qu'il ya
dessous est dans ce que vous venez de
dire c'est que quand on est on
arrive avec notre casquette de chercheur
on veut écrire des livres sur ce milieu
et on voit les choses avec des lunettes
spécifiques des lunettes avec des d une
méthode de chercheurs des hypothèses de
serveurs et donc on
pouvait pas voir ce milieu comme vous le
venez de le dire mais pas le physique
pour porter des talons 18 cm peut-être
nous à 2,8 cm dans huit 18 ans attend
maintenant mais je portais quand même
des talons je portais des petits
tailleurs alors c'était pas chanel parce
que j'avais pas les moyens mais entre
promod et 1 2 3 et j'arrivais quand même
quand on est mince ça va ça on arrive à
s'en sortir et michel on lui acheter un
costume croisé bleu marine mais dès le
premier entretien et il l'a toujours
aimé
pas d'autres marc piguet
vous poignée n'en connaissez non c'est
une petite notre oui en fait c'est un
des atours pour pouvoir à qui ce genre
de cercle et revenons à une question
internet qui
l'avenir sur le court et moyen terme de
cette de cette caste alors
bertold brecht disait d'eux qu'ils
déprend dépend l'oppression de
nous deux qui dépend tels des deux qui
dépend t-il de qui dépend celle des deux
qui dépend tive que cette oppression
cesse de nous c'est à dire je répondrai
à cet internaute c'est
nous qui avons tous les pouvoirs c'est
nous qui faisons fonctionner l'économie
réelle c'est nous qui sommes les plus
nombreux et on se laisse oppressé
opprimés on se laisse déshumanisé
esclavagisé par une petite caste qui
s'est accaparé avec le système
capitaliste toutes
les richesses et tous les pouvoirs tous
les dominos aujourd'hui bascule en leur
faveur warren buffet a déclaré en 2005
nous sommes effectivement dans une
guerre de classes c'est nous les riches
qui la menons et c'est nous qui sommes
en train de la gagner eh bien nous nous
nous pensons que il est tout à fait
possible de renverser les dominos dans
l'autre sens à la condition et à la
seule condition que nous nous unissions
au delà de nos divisions au delà de nos
égos au delà de tout ce qui nous sépare
pour sauver tout simplement la planète
et l'humanité puisque c'est pas trop
tard c'est pas c'est pas un peu du
wishful thinking je vais dur je vais me
faire vraiment l'avocat du diable là ça
fait peut-être 30 40 ans que
les banlieues est où les les classes
très moyennes moyennes sont dans une
situation de stress en avoir accès
correctement avec culture sans avoir
accès à tous ces codes sans avoir accès
à toutes les méthodes de déchiffrement
de deux de ses codes sociaux avec
la
peur de perdre son emploi la peur de la
violence dans les quartiers sur ses
enfants la peur de la femme qui voit
sont mariés allaient tous les week-ends
au turbin où c'est chaud comme ça avec
dédé épigénétiques
sur ces classes sociales connaissez
l'épigénétique une
épigénétiques dur sélectionnant
des gens qui courent blé chine pensait
pas que ce n'est pas trop tard face à
une casse qui a l'argent le pouvoir la
culture les réseaux la capacité de
couardise pour pouvoir garder son
pouvoir parce que peut-être elle à elle
a peur de la guillotine et
elle a peur est la peur de la guillotine
ils ont peur par exemple dès qu'il ya eu
les premières manifestations des gilet
jaune c'est clair que dans les beaux
quartiers il y avait la peur tandis
que dans le marché ce que j'appelle le
marché de la contestation sociale dans
lequel on baigne michelle et moi c'est à
dire on fait nos livres fait un peu en
examen ab oui on ad'autres nos est venu
combien on gagne alors on a notre
retraite j'ai deux communes alors que je
vous dise pas de bêtises moi c'est 2000
et michel ses 3000 peut-être 3500 3000
dans suis sûr qu'elle 3000 et puis on a
à peu près chaque année environ 10000
euros de droits d'auteur chacun mais ça
dépend des années parce que quand on a
fait le best seller sur le président des
riches ça a été beaucoup plus du main
basse sur plus de cent mille euros et là
on a pu s'acheter une kangoo rouge on a
pu re fait refaire le toit de notre
maison se fait remettre des vitres cas
par cas dans toute notre maison pour
avoir plus froid et plus quand il fait
pour se protéger des canicules et
puis des voyages que de la générosité
voilà puis cesser ces fines et on en
parle plus et
donc le marché de la contestation
sociale donc avec les syndicats les
partis politiques avec les la course aux
élections tout ce tout ça ce qui est qui
est devenu un peu plan-plan qui avait
qui s'est institué qui c'est et je crois
que justement ce qui se passe avec les
gilet jaune et tout de suite nous on a
dit c'est le vous nous avez rendus vous
nous êtes en train de nous rendre le
grand service du siècle c'est que tout a
été bousculé ils n'ont pas respecté les
corps intermédiaires et n'ont pas
respecté les lieux de manifestation tout
de suite les lieux de pouvoir au plus
près de macron au plus près des des
ministres
au plus près des députés enfin et je
peux vous assurer que là il d'ailleurs
vous savez très bien qu'ils ont très
peur puisque les forces de police exerce
une violence physique à l'égard des
gilet jaune qui est tout simplement
incroyable
inwi nos dignes de l'egypte
c'est parfait on n'a pas encore les
snipers sur les toits mais bon dis moi
on a les snipers sur les toits mais pas
pour les mêmes raisons autre question
d'internet on va la prendre sans la lire
sentez vous que la population
s'intéresse davantage au fonctionnement
des institutions politiques et d
économie politique
économique pardon oui est ce qu'après le
mouvement des gilet jaune ouais il ya eu
quand même une prise de conscience d'un
retard sur l'ajout d'une passivité
intellectuelle sur certains sujets qui
était devenue délétère est-ce que vous
pensez que
la communauté de gilet jaune ou comme
dirait certains de nos présidents
laissant dans les gens qui ne sont rien
les gens de peu 1 ont pris conscience
qu'il fallait quand même heureux serez
intéressé ou rouages de certaines
fonctions du moins certains certaine
aisance et certaines institutions oui
c'est vrai que les gilets jaunes ont mis
en avant l'institution
politiques en réclamant le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne en réclamant le
tirage au sort enfin mais pour nous les
contacts qu'on a avec les gilets jaunes
sont beaucoup plus intéressant que ça
c'est à dire que alors bien entendu tout
est biaisé puisque c'est nous qui
discutant avec eux c'est eux qui
viennent nous voir c'est nous qui allons
les voir donc ils connaissent notre
sociologie parce que ce grâce à des
émissions comme beaucoup d'émissions sur
internet c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent pour acheter nos
livres mais ils se servent beaucoup des
vidéos sur internet pour comprendre
honnêtement c'est fou l'intelligence des
ronds points cédés véritable université
populaire c'est fou comment ces
gens là cause qu'on croyait foutu mais
pas je leur jette pas la pierre parce
que leur vie était trop difficile
toujours loin toujours dans leur bagnole
à rouler justement tous ces ronds points
ou 2 c sans graisse qui tous ces ronds
points et tout ça
comment ils l'intelligence
de classe de ces gens là c'est fou et
même je vous dirais qu'il faut c'est ça
à côté de militants encartés depuis des
années je me dit bon voilà on sent de
delà de la fraîcheur de classe une
conscience de classe extrêmement forte
est ce que pour vous c'est ce qu'on peut
faire un parallèle avec la période des
cahiers de doléances ça
je suis pas suffisamment historienne
pour
vraiment pour moi je dirais oui il ya
quelque chose qui a à voir maintenant
est-ce que ça je pense qu'il ya dans le
mouvement des gels et jaune je le dis je
suis persuadé que sa nasse c'est quelque
chose qui ne va pas s'arrêter c'est
quelque chose qui est qui
est beaucoup plus fort qui
qui s'inscrit autrement que dans ce que
ce marché de la contestation sociale que
j'ai essayé d'écrire qui nous bousculent
et qui va être extrêmement positif c'est
à dire qu' il va falloir qu'on s'unisse
au delà de
nos divisions de nos sensibilités
différentes
on est très nombreux donc six ans en
sciences respectent pas les uns les
autres on y arrivera pas et pourquoi ça
va se faire aujourd'hui
je rebondis vous avez dit tout à l'heure
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard je pense
que c'est peut-être trop tard mais en
même temps je crois je veux espérer que
le dérèglement climatique va
permettre l'interconnexion de toutes les
inégalités et va permettre à la
conscience de classe de se généraliser
et de se dire mais c'est pas possible
c'est passé cette petite caste qui va
qui va nous tuer parce que finalement au
final avec le dérèglement climatique
quels tel qu'il s'annonce c'est bien la
partie la plus pauvre de l'humanité qui
va mourir que d'habitude comme
d'habitude
bien sûr parce que c'est les gens les
plus pauvres qui peuvent pas se protéger
déjà en afrique je ne sais pas combien
il ya deux millions de morts chaque
année qui sont recensés au titre du
dérèglement climatique au bangladesh
avec les inondations et le niveau des
mers qui monte il ya déjà plusieurs
millions de gens qui sont recensés à ce
titre là et moi vous voyez quand quand
on dit il ya vingt-six milliardaires qui
possèdent autant que la moitié la plus
pauvre de l'humanité puis quand vous le
redis de tout ça moi je pense qu'on nous
dit les riches font sécession je pense
que c'est trop gentil comme expression
c'est les riches qui mène la guerre
contre les pauvres et ses riches ils
essayent de nous habituer à ça c'est à
dire à ce que ça va devenir normal de se
dire que on va quand même pas nourrir
des bouches qui ne servent plus à rien
et on ne va quand même pas protéger des
gens du dérèglement climatique ça va
nous coûter trop cher est
ce que vous êtes tentés ainsi
au phénomène de guerre économique et de
cette opr classe apatrides
parce que là on a parlé simplement de la
haute bourgeoisie qui est à notre sens
simplement les seconds couteaux les
petits joueurs vous n'êtes pas intéressé
en termes de guerre économique dampierre
financiers autres que les petits joueurs
baa séance qui l'intéressé c'est à dire
on a travaillé sur
la fraude fiscale a évidemment à
l'échelle internationale puisque avec
les paradis fiscaux on est obligé de
travailler à l'échelle de la planète
alors
j'ai guerre économique après je vous
laisse terminer sur les paradis fiscaux
oui alors comment
vous dire j'ai là c'est vrai que j'ai
parlé j'ai pas donné les par exemple
j'ai pas indiqué les professions des
gens
qu'on pouvait interviewer mais par
exemple cette aide et des banquiers de
très haut niveau vous avez très new
directeur
général du bs très
hautes fonctions à directeur même
adjoint à la bnp paribas 25 si vous
n'êtes jamais fait non oui ces ragots
non
je vois très bien ce que vous voulez
dire mais moi je m'en fous de ce que
deux parce que au fond ce qui a été
intéressant dans notre travail c'était
quand même d'approché d'approché
d'approché même si on n'a pas été au
coeur comme peut-être vous vous pouvez
l'être moi j'en sais rien ou d'autres on
a compris comment ça fonctionnait et
comment il avait mis au point des armes
financières des
armes de destruction de
destruction massive
du travail du
travail d'autrui du qu'est ce que je
pourrais dire comment ils ont ils
spéculent comment les lecteurs je me
rappelle plus toutes les truanderie
qu'ils ont fait le libor enfin les
'subprimes' en ce moment là les produits
dérivés par rapport justement au
derrière poule et on opposera l'armée
pourquoi vous n'avez pas eu une approche
plus plutôt
cheap c'est à dire vous
intéresser à l'industrie qui tourne
autour c'est à dire et les concierges
d'hôtels les
prostituées
les fournisseurs de drogue des
fournisseurs de conduites addictives x
ou y les les boîtes un peu chaude ou des
choses comme ça vous n'avez jamais fait
ce côté là pas du tout pas
du tout mais je pense que c'est à la aux
déviances de ses deux portes s c'est
à dire que si parce que la phase
déviance en ces temps on s'est centrée
sur leur violence de classe leur
violence de classe c'est à dire dans
dans la le rapport aux autres classes et
au monde du travail à travers les
délocalisations à travers toutes
les lois puisqu'au fond cette classe
sociale elle elle arrive avec
la complicité des politiques à
transformer ses intérêts privés en
intérêt général ça devient la loi alors
que c'est leurs lois leurs droits
devient le droit donc nous c'est ce
fonctionnement là que nous avons essayé
de bien comprendre et
de décrire de livre en livre bien
entendu que on aurait aimé pouvoir
rentrer
plus plus au fond d'eux du coeur
nucléaire mais que ça nous n'y avions
pas accès et que au fond ça
aurait été bien mais on n'y avaient pas
accès on n'y avaient pas accès et
parce qu'il aurait fallu quoique je veux
qu'il fallait faire c'était une autre
démarche
c'était déjà bien salée faire un mètre
76 vous présentez comme célibataire
quittez pas c'était très facile non je
rigole mais c'est très vrai mais je
crois bien mais parce que vous parce que
voilà comprenez
pourquoi je comprends très bien je
vais vous envoyer quelques questions
d'internet alors
entre guillemets laisser mourir les plus
faibles l'euthanasie est elle à l'ordre
du jour
question internet ouais ok sur internet
dans ce système sommes nous à la fois
victimes et bourreaux est-ce que vous
avez des conseils pour les gilet jaune
et
campagne comme la drôme en dira la suite
sar est vrai par comment entrevoyez-vous
l'après capitalisme
s'il y avait près de capitalisme alors
la première c'était sur l'euthanasie non
je pense que cette cette oligarchie a
mis au point d'autres armes que celles
du meurtre avec le canon et la
mitraillette ou ce type d'armes létales
que le dérèglement climatique va être
véritablement larmes
qui va qui
va détruire cette partie la plus pauvre
de l'humanité mais il est encore temps
d'agir mais vraiment là
il ya quelque chose de très grave qui
est en train de se jouer et que révèle
justement l'irruption des gilet jaune à
propos de l'augmentation des taxes sur
le carburant ou tristement pour rien
lorsque aux questions internet comment
un analyste elle le fait que la société
reste relativement stable malgré le
déséquilibre flagrant de richesse parce
que ben yahia il ya une dictature il ya
un autoritarisme qui s'est mis en place
si vous voulez le système capitaliste
tel qu'il évolue avec le néolibéralisme
aujourd'hui vous avez fait plusieurs
émissions là dessus ce moment où là
disons la finance prend le pouvoir sur
le politique prend le pouvoir sur la
communication le monde des médias macron
par exemple il a été placé à l'elysée
par des puissances d'argent par des
donateurs par des des puissances
d'argent je suis pas dans tous les
secrets mais je m'imagine que il ya des
choses que je ne sais pas on a découvert
avec sarkozy que finalement il s'était
quand même fait payer 50 millions
d'euros
par la libye pour sa campagne des
présidentielles en 2007 donc je sais
qu'on sait pas tout mais voilà l'argent
permet de s'approprier y compris le bien
commun qu'est le politique et du coup ça
fait cher le dossier ça fait qu' on est
piégé en égard aux t on est
et
en un petit schisme qui est disloquée on
est tétanisé en ce sens impuissant en on
se sent dans
l'incapacité et
par exemple moi je me dis bon ok tu
écris tes livres mais est-ce que tu
serais capable c'est
pas de faire de la désobéissance civile
est ce que tu serais capable de faire
quelque chose de d'aller plus loin
puisque tu dis des choses qui sont
graves tu peux pas rester tranquilles ou
danton dans ton canapé ton fauteuil aux
questions internet comment cette classe
parle-t-elle du peuple quel vocabulaire
se rend elle compte de
leurs violents se rend-il compte de leur
violence alors
écoutez les les faits les faits parlent
tout seul tout à l'heure vous avez
repris le terme de françois hollande
laissant dans moi
je vais parler de la façon dont macron
parle de ddd des ouvriers des gens donc
c'est des fainéants des extrêmes c'est
des coups ces décharges c'est ta qu'à
traverser la rue pour aller voir et puis
tout tout tout ce qu'il a tout ce qu'il
a tout ce qu'il a pu dire le mépris de
classe il est là à
la chasse à courre quand ce télé parce
qu'il ya ceux qui sont à cheval et puis
il ya les légendes qui font les découpes
lecerf et e on les appelle les petits
pères voyez des expressions comme ça les
petits pères et et puis alors a donc ça
c'est dans les intérêts dans les
interactions mais sinon globalement
lorsque la mairie de paris décide
quand bertrand delanoë arrive en 2001 à
l'hôtel de ville de mettre des logements
sociaux d'appliquer la loi sru dans
les arrondissements qui refuse
les hlm les logements sociaux eh bien ça
a été ça a été la guerre c'est à dire
que c'est allé très loin alors ne
parlons pas de ian brossât le maire
adjoint communiste actuelle qui a voulu
mettre un centre d'hébergement d'urgence
au pied des plus grandes fortunes
wildenstein d'assaut et autres blanchard
dignac alors là ça
a été très violent il
et voilà ils se battent ils n'en veulent
pas c'est à dire que ils veulent rester
entre eux parce que cet entre soi est
essentiel pour le fonctionnement comme
on l'a vu au début de l'émission est
essentielle au fonctionnement à la
mobilisation de cette classe et à la
défense des intérêts il faut toujours
qu'il soit entre eux pour toujours
échangées il faut toujours qu'il soit
entre eux pour éviter les mésalliances
il faut toujours qu'il soit entre eux
pour construire ce sentiment d'impunité
qui n'est pas seulement un sentiment
c'est une vraie impunité puisque les
gens de la justice les gens du politique
le monde des affaires tout le monde se
réunit dans la mayonnaise delà de la
sociabilité mondaine vos questions
internet que pensez-vous des black
blocks alors
ça je sais pas trop qui sait je sais pas
qui sont les black blocks je sais
simplement qu'une fois il ya une une
jeune fille qui est venue faire une
vidéo chez moi pour moi et je lui ai dit
que y ait rejeté la veille j'étais
devant l'assemblée nationale à une
manifestation tout de suite après
l'arrivée de macron donc c'est septembre
2017 et elle me dit qu'elle y était
aussi et elle me dit qu'elle est black
bloc et donc je lui ai dit mais alors
c'est vous qui étiez là c'est vous qui
avez gâché notre manifestation parce
qu'ils sont partis attaqué la police
alors que pour la première fois ont
manifesté place de la concorde dans les
beaux quartiers sur les lieux de pouvoir
face à l'assemblée nationale ce qui est
notre combat avec michel de dire c'est
dans les lieux de pouvoir qu'il faut
manifester au plus près des puissants il
faut les faire vivre sur le pied de le
pied de guerre et pour ça il faut être
visible il faut faire du bruit et alba
did assume pas ce que je vais dire vous
avez qu à expliquer pourquoi vous casser
l a10 et c'est plus fort que moi il faut
que je casse faut que je casse enfin
c'est le lasso la seule fois où j'ai eu
à un dialogue et une interaction avec un
membre des black blocks je ne sais pas
qui c'est je ne sais je sais rien est ce
que vous pensez que la non violence est
depuis son nas
et moi je réponds à cette question en
disant moi mon combat c'est la violence
des riches la violence des riches c'est
une violence qui est terrible c'est une
violence qui tue c'est une violence qui
empêche les plus démunis de
se projeter dans l'avenir de
ne pas pouvoir anticiper les générations
suivantes c'est une génération qui vous
qui vous brisent le corps c'est une
c'est une violence qui tue l'amour qui
tue l'amitié qui tue votre humanité
cette violence des riches par rapport
même à ce que font les black blocks quoi
ce qu'ont pu faire les gilet jaune sais
rien voilà la violence des riches on a
écrit tout un livre sur la violence des
riches s'est totalement accablant c'est
le plus grand casse qui puisse exister
le plus grand casse social l'économique
c'est que l'on ait musique et c'est
hélas
on en arrive à la destruction de
la planète c'est pas rien ce qui est en
train de se passer une question
d'internet que pense-t-elle de la
démocratie directe foot il s'éloigne et
de la démocratie représentative
ah bah oui ça la démocratie représente
la démocratie je dirais pseudo
représentative elle est complètement
arrimer on le voit très bien avec macron
à au système capitaliste à la
soi-disante démocratie c'est à dire que
ils ne peuvent pas exploiter
le peuple mener la guerre contre le
peuple sans nous raconter l'histoire que
ils le font au nom des droits de l'homme
et de la démocratie
on arrive bientôt la fin notre interview
est-ce que vous avez des choses à
aborder avec nous que je n'aurais pas
dit je
sais pas d'abord je dirais que je me
sens bien là d'avoir pu parler
avec vous que vous m'ayez fait sentir
les limites de
notre travail c'est à dire comme nous on
est toujours avec michel quand on fait
des rencontres qu'on présente des livres
en librairie on est toujours face à des
gens qui sont complètement démunis par
rapport à ce que nous on sait déjà qu'on
a l'impression qu'on a on a fait
beaucoup alors en réalité j'ai bien
conscience qu'on a simplement lever
un petit coin du voile et
qu' il ya du travail et que pour faire
ce travail il faut être nombreux il faut
être il
faut qu'ils les lanceurs d'alerté de
partout il faut qu'ils aient plein de
gens qui activent l'article
40 du
code pénal il faut qu'ils aient les
salariés qui
est plein de gens qui parlent sous
anonymat s'ils veulent pas être lanceur
d'alert voilà nous il ya des c'est comme
ça aussi qu'on travaille vous a déjà
planté dans votre travail vous avez déjà
fait des bourdes vous avez déjà fait des
mauvaises interprétations qu'avec
les chiffres que vous utilisiez mais
je pense pas est-ce que vous avez déjà
est-ce qu'on vous ait déjà fac tchéquie
c'est
à dire que il ya eu par rapport à
emmanuel macron et les cadeaux qu'il a
fait en dizaines de milliards aux plus
riches il ya eu juste un tout petit en
tout petit désaccord avec un économiste
de libération parce qu'on avait on a
écrit ce qui est juste que l' isf il l'a
supprimée donc il a supprimé les valeurs
mobilières du stock de patrimoine
mobilier des plus riches mais que pour
les revenus du capital qui était imposé
comme les salaires de manière
progressive de 14 à 45 % pour
la première fois depuis la 5ème
république depuis la libération je sais
pas il a instauré un forfait sur
l'imposition pour l'imposition des
revenus du capital en dessous de la
première tranche d'imposition des
salaires à 14% et pour le capital
aujourd'hui c'est 12 8% est ce que vous
vous rendez compte que bernard arnault
qui récoltent des centaines de millions
de dividendes chaque année va payer si
pour ce qui payera en france parce qu'il
ya les paradis fiscaux il ya tout le
reste la holding en belgique et tout ça
pour ce qui va payer en france il va
payer 12 8% de manière forfaitaire ce
qui est contraire je pense je parle sous
votre contrôle ce qui est contraire à
notre constitution et à la déclaration
des droits de l'homme où on doit payer
ses impôts de manière progressive en
fonction de sa fortune d'abord
libération soulève en février 2009 que
les pinçon charlot commettent une erreur
grossière et confond le taux marginal
d'imposition avec le taux effectif
d'imposition ce qui leur permet
d'affirmer à tort le plus mal payé des
contribuables paient plus d'impôt sur le
revenu que le riche que les plus riches
des actionnaires sur chaque roue de
dividendes perçus oui alors là c'est
parce que franchement je suis pas je
reste pas d'accord avec ça dans la
mesure où on dit que la première tranche
d'imposition c zéro pour les salariés
puisque d'une part il ya tous ceux qui
sont pas imposables mais pour ceux qui
sont imposables il ya cette transe que
j'arrive toujours pas à comprendre qui
va de 0 à 14 % mais pour moi quand on
paye ses impôts ça commence à 14% avant
je les paye pas soutient le monde qui
critiquent les pinçon charlot pour
l'absence totale de rigueur scientifique
dans leur ouvrage le président des
ultras riches les pinçon charlot croit
observer la science imperturbable
et le goût de l'autre sous de la
bourgeoisie coupé du reste de la société
en s'efforçant de maintenir les touches
vous
avez quelque chose à leur répondent au
monde a bien sûr c'est à dire que quand
on sait quand on sait pas quoi dire sur
le contenu d'un livre comme le président
des ultras riches sachant que le monde a
quand même que nous lisons cinq jours a
beaucoup beaucoup travaillé pour
propulser
macron à l'elysée qui a je pense pas de
faute grave dans notre livre en tout cas
qu'on est on a fait un travail sérieux
très sourd c'est un travail collectif
d'ailleurs aussi qu'il ya qu'à mobiliser
des
gens qui nous ont aidés qui sont
remerciés dans le livre notre éditeur
notamment 10
les travaux ne peuvent ainsi en aucun
cas être qualifié de travaux
sociologiques en vedette voilà il ne
cesse de prétendre les étayée par des
moyens sociologique ce qui est inexact
et ce qui est totalement alors nous
c'est totalement vrai quand le ce livre
comme tout le reste des 25 autres livres
qu'on a écrit à quatre mains mobilise
les outils de la sociologie et là c'est
simplement qu'ils ont ils pouvaient plus
monopolisé la théorie du complot et ans
et on avait déjà trop répondu et donc
ces mêmes allés très loin parce que à un
autre sociologue qui éditocrates au
point édito
et qui se réclame de la sociologie a pu
demander à ce que nous soyons poursuivis
devant les tribunaux pour usurpation
imposture usurpation infondées
d'une discipline scientifique et
donc si vous voulez non nous alors
vraiment là on est con on est on est on
est peinards on est tranquille avec nous
mêmes ce sont des modalités de pour nous
déstabiliser pour nous stigmatiser
auxquels
je réponds tout tranquillement devant
vous avec un sourire qui n'est pas aussi
généreux que ce que je voudrais mais que
nous prenons comme on alors vous allez
dire vous êtes contents de vous je pense
qu'on a fait du bon travail avec michel
vraiment je pense qu'on a fait un
travail qui qui est important livre
après livre comme deux moines
bénédictins soutoul
et de tous les côtés on a essayé
d'attraper cette oligarchie de
transmettre le savoir accumulé non
pas aux autres chercheurs mais à eau ou
peuple de france enfin aux gens les plus
je vous dis allez faire des jeux apéro
dans le camping des maths sous la flotte
au mois de juillet de je ne sais quelle
année on n'a pas ménagé notre peine est
je pense que voilà
il faut que la relève se prennent que
notre travail puisse continuer à servir
à aider à ce qu'on se sorte de
cette oppression qui qui nous tue autre
question d'internet et puis après avoir
été question internet et yahoo que
pensez-vous des courants féministes
actuelle je suis pas très au courant
j'ai pas très au courant des mouvements
féministes c'est à dire que je
ne suis jamais arrivé à être vraiment
d'accord avec la théorie du genre et
tout ça donc je suis pas je suis pas à
l'aise avec cette question tu préfères
pas répondre aux questions que pensez
vous des émissions de type cash
investigations révèlent tels des choses
embarrassantes pour le goulot de guerchy
ou est ce que ce sont les miettes pour
distraire le peuple maintenant
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
intéressants dans ses émissions cash
investigations pièces à conviction
complément d'enquêté sais pas si ça
continue à exister donc
il ya beaucoup envoyé spécial il ya
beaucoup de choses intéressantes qui
doivent mettre mal à l'aise mais
après il faut faire quelque chose de ces
informations il faut faire quelque chose
de se savoir il faut que ça aide à la
prise de conscience et à l'envi de la
révolte à la compréhension qui a que
nous que c'est nous qui sommes complices
de notre propre tous les esprits ah oui
mais après les faits une fois que les
esprits sont révoltés sont bien faits le
corps suit c'est
à dire question d'internet l'oligarchie
at elle conscience de sa propre
destruction je
pense que oui parce que le fait le fait
qu'ils soient toujours sur leur qui vive
quand il ya des grands mouvements
sociaux alors là pour les gilet jaune on
était plus on n'était plus acceptée dans
les beaux quartiers donc mais en 1995
quand il ya eu les grands mouvements
contre juppé avec les retraites la sncf
et tout ça on
était là avec eux et franchement les
valises étaient prêtes ils sont plus
goût du fer dans duke il
ils
ont en mémoire la révolution française
ils ont en mémoire tous les grands
mouvements ils ont en mémoire 1936
ils savent très bien qu'en 1936 ils ont
dû lâcher sur les congés payés sur les
salaires des ouvriers et surtout les
avantages que les ouvrières ont obtenu
en occupant les usines en occupant en
faisant la grève illimitée avec
occupation d'usiné c'est pas par les
élections que ça a été serge halimi le
montre bien dans le grand bond en
arrière et donc suffirait
que on décide tous de se mettre en grève
les ouvriers les les dockers tous ceux
qui conduisent les moyens de transport
enfin on s'arrête tous de travailler
tout est bloqué il sent plus rien on
arrive à la dernière question qui n'est
pas une question et laissez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer et juste avant cinq
conseillers trois livres par
trois livres alors j'ai déjà cité la
bande dessinée sarkozy rada fille qui a
été publié chez delcourt le seuil et qui
est absolument hallucinante avec fabrice
arfi benoît collombat j'ai pas retenu
tous tes sources et et voilà
donc on apprend que ils n'ont pas eu de
menaces 50 millions d'euros ont été
versés à nicolas sarkozy pour sa
campagne des présidentielles de 2007
ensuite quelqu'un que vous avez reçus
ici denis robert et catherine le gall
donc
vous l'avez pas reçue mais je dis je dis
l'autre auteur de ce livre pour un livre
superbe sur la façon dont l'état
français par exemple pour le pas le
passage de leur livre qui concerne le la
vente de quick les prédateurs les prêts
alors le titre c'est les prédateurs des
milliardaires contre l'état et c'est
donc la façon dont des milliardaires
comme albert frère et paul desmarais
peuvent piller l'état français avec des
complicités au plus haut niveau à bercy
et donc c'est une enquête magnifique et
ce livre là je les trouvais vraiment
vraiment très très intéressant très fort
et qui va plus loin que ce que nous on a
fait c'est à dire que là vraiment l'
enquête
est une véritable enquête
d'investigation c'est pas le même
registre que du travail sociologique
comme nous on a fait à l'échelle d'une
classe sociale qu'est
ce que le troisième alors il manque un
troisième alors la casse de laurent
mauduit bien sûr j'en
avais un autre que j'ai sur le bout de
la langue et puis s'amuse m pas tout
d'un coup pas
si ça y est je le retrouve de tanguy
viel un roman édité aux éditions demi
nue article
353 du code pénal un
conseil pour les jeunes générations eh
ben il faut il faut vraiment prendre
conscience de
l'individualisme
négatif dans lequel vous
tous vous avez été construit avec
l'éducation que vous recevez dans
cette société néolibérale et qu'il faut
transformer cet individualisme négatif
en un individualisme positif de liberté
et de progrès social mans partager voilà
monique
pinçon-charlot merci merci à vous merci
beaucoup coupé
[Musique]